welcome to Hannity like a false prophet
of moral righteousness James Comey
former FBI director constantly
pretending to be a courageous hero
fighting for truth and justice in
reality he is a hateful vengeful
arrogant narcissist we now know who
abused power and fostered one of the
most corrupt federal departments this
country has ever seen
but tonight we can report the walls are
closing in on James Comey we have yet
another major development in our Hannity
watch on the deep state former FBI
General Counsel James Baker the man who
served as Jim Comey's top lawyer he too
like others is now under criminal
investigation for leaking to the media
and Baker has long face scrutiny over
his ties to Mother Jones reporter David
corn remember corn was the first
journalist to report the existence of
Christopher Steele's dirty dossier in
the lead-up to the 2016 presidential
election so let's keep track of commis
leadership at the FBI you know mr.
integrity okay now of course we know
Comey himself was fired by President
Trump his second-in-command Andrew
McCabe was fired for lying Andrew McCabe
is now currently under a criminal
investigation commis top investigator
Peter struck well he was fired for his
obvious political bias he may soon be
under criminal investigation as well as
his ex-girlfriend top FBI lawyer Lisa
Paige she was forced to resign over her
bias then he got commis chief of staff
James rebecky he's resigned and now we
know commis general counsel Jim Baker
now we can report under an official
criminal investigation something call me
himself that he admitted to doing when
he leaked in FBI memos about President
Trump remembered to his professor friend
at Columbia and then to the New York
Times for the very purpose of spurring a
Special Counsel investigation which
coincidentally well that's being carried
out by commis close friend Robert Muller
how nice so what did all the people I
just list have in common they all wanted
Hillary
to win one of them 100 million to zero
they all hated and continued to hate
Donald Trump they all work together to
rig our political system and fix the
outcome of the 2016 election by using
their powerful top positions not
rank-and-file the top positions the FBI
and the DOJ to help Hillary Clinton win
to cheat to rig an election and as we
now know they had an insurance policy
and a media leak strategy in case
Clinton didn't win a hundred million is
zero now after dreams Comey was fired
top officials inside the FBI they were
angry they acted out of that anger
malice emotion without any evidence no
probable cause or reasonable suspicion
and ended up launching what was a
partisan investigation into the
President of the United States with a
wild conspiracy accusing the president
of working with Vladimir Putin to fire
Comey because Russia told him to do it
no evidence they were angry this was
their punishment this was their payback
abusing power to attack the president
that they never want elected now this
brings us tonight to a Hannity history
lesson Glenn Greenwald recently pointed
out that the FBI and their investigation
into Donald Trump used eerily similar
tactics to those pioneered by J Edgar
Hoover remember Hoover served as an FBI
director for many decades and he became
infamous for his aggressive
investigations into Americans who he
suspected had ties to the Soviet Union
Hoover even suspected FDR's vice
president Henry Wallace to be a to a
lengthy probe and surveillance simply
because Hoover disagreed with Wallace's
policy the FBI should never be in the
business of investigating political
differences or policy decisions they
shouldn't be while lashing out because
of personal opinions that they have the
role of the FBI which is the 99 percent
of field agents of rank-and-file they do
their job they investigate crimes and
criminals not politics not policy and
especially not launching a
counterintelligence and
negation into a duly elected president
with zero evidence because you don't
like him
now today William bar president Trump's
pick to be our next Attorney General
faced his first day of confirmation
hearings on the hill Senator Lindsey
Graham will join us later grilled him
about whether or not he would
investigate the FBI's baseless corrupt
investigation into President Trump
taken out of anger for the firing or
combing let's take a look so we should
always be on guard about the politician
interfering in a investigation but we
should also have oversight of how the
department works in those with this
tremendous power use that power are you
familiar with the January 11th New York
Times article about FBI open inquiry
into whether Trump was secretly working
on behalf of Russians yes mr. chairman
would you promise me in this committee
to look into this and tell us whether or
not in the appropriate way a
counterintelligence investigation was
opened up by somebody at the FBI /
Department of Justice against President
Trump yes mr. Chairman I think there are
a number of investigations as I
understand it going on in the department
you have heard of such a thing and all
the time you've been associated with the
Department of Justice I have never heard
of that are they rules about how you can
do counterintelligence investigations I
believe there are mr. chairman so if you
want to open up one against the
president are there any checks and
balances not outside the FBI okay well
we need to look at that
in terms of people who are actually
enforcing the law don't we want to make
sure they don't have an agenda that's
right mr. chairman
do you promise me as Attorney General if
you get this job to look in to see what
happened in 2016 yes mr. chairman so
that's a good sign that William bar
cares about equal justice equal
application of our laws and saying that
he will serve as a fair Attorney General
mr. Barr there are no shortage of
corrupt Trump haters to investigate and
many with a lot of power that they've
abused no shortage of crimes here and
tonight we're going to begin to lay out
a road map of corruption for the new
Attorney General to be our own gregg
jarrett has compiled a comprehensive
list we're going to start we're not
going to go through the full list
tonight with FISA abuse that is lying to
a FISA Court that is committing a fraud
against the court to get a warrant to
spy on a trump campaign associate using
Hillary Clinton's bought and paid for
phony dossier that was full of Russian
lies look at your screen James Comey
Andrew McCabe Sally Yates Rod Rosenstein
all likely committed fraud on a FISA
Court by presenting Hillary Clinton's
dirty dossier as unbiased verified
evidence when reality it was never
verified never corroborated and full of
Russian lies and they never told the
courts that it was bought and paid for
by Hillary Clinton next up mr. Barr you
get this job you need to look into the
theft and the leaking of government
documents Jim Comey obviously committed
a serious crime when he intentionally
leaked his FBI memos about his
conversations with the president it's
important also look at abuse of power
charges that would be many of the same
names Comey McCabe struck all-fired lisa
page resign and shame Bruce or demoted
twice should have been fired all using
their high positions in our federal
government to persecute those they
disagreed with politically all trying to
help Hillary Clinton get elected and
then having an insurance policy and a
media leak strategy if in fact Donald
Trump did win and let's not forget about
lying to the FBI after all this crime
shouldn't only apply to an America war
hero like general Flynn and Trump
campaign staff like George papadopolis
oh I had to spend two weeks in jail for
nothing
Andrew McCabe was literally fired over
that charge is he going to receive the
same treatment as general Flynn and be
prosecuted now the DOJ also will need to
tackle the unauthorized leaks we now
know that James Baker is already facing
a criminal investigation tonight over
this charge but so too
we got a look at John Brennan
and James clapper and what about Susan
Rice and what about Samantha power
should they not be investigated over the
massive amounts of names that they
unmask while serving in the final year
the Obama administration and because of
James commis biased and inept
investigation of Hillary Clinton an
exoneration before an investigation
obvious violation of the Espionage Act
mr. Barr must also revisit Hillary
Clinton's various crimes like Oh the
leading subpoenaed emails and deleting
your hard drive and washing it with
bleach bit and busting up devices and
ripping out SIM cards we will show you
exactly how Mr Barra should tackle that
in tomorrow night's monologue but first
let's get back to bars testimony on
Capitol Hill earlier today in a
concerning statement he actually said
that the Moller investigation is not a
witch-hunt I strongly disagree
take a look you say you've known Muller
a long time would you say you have a
close relationship with mr. Muller I
would say we were good friends would you
say that you understand him to be a
fair-minded person absolutely do you
trust him to be fair to the president
and the country as a whole
yes when his report comes to you will
you share it with us as much as possible
consistent with regulations and the law
yes do you believe mr. Muller would be
involved in a witch-hunt against anybody
I don't I don't believe mr. Muller would
would be involved in a witch-hunt now
maybe we can assume Barr is just trying
to placate Democratic fears giving the
benefit of the doubt not rushing to
judgment a belief in innocence before
being proven guilty because we know in
fact Robert Muller is on a witch hunt
you need to look no further than the
people that Muller hired we're talking
about multiple big-time Democratic
donors those that made tens of thousands
of dollars combined and contributions to
the campaign's of Obamacare or Clinton
and other Democrats Muller
he hired zero Republicans not one top
molar attorney jeanne ray actually
worked for Hillary Clinton how could you
hire Hillary Clinton's attorney at the
Clinton Foundation and Muller so-called
pit
according to the New York Times Andrew
Weissman well he actually attended
Hillary's election night party and
Weissman has also come under fire for
his hyper aggressive aggressive
prosecution tactics like withholding if
you read Sidney Powell's license to lie
withholding exculpatory evidence
including one case Anderson accounting
they were forced to close their doors
tens of thousands of people lost their
jobs before the Supreme Court overturned
Weissman's prosecution nine to zero in
another case Muller's pit bull Wiseman
said four innocent Merrill Lynch
executives to prison for a year you'll
never get that year back in your life
before that case was overturned by the
Fifth Circuit Court of Appeals so we're
supposed to believe that that track
record appointing those people that
that's a fair unbiased investigation
that's being carried out by an obvious
aggressive partisan team of lawyers that
Muller picked don't forget he also
picked struck in Page we know where they
stand now we're gonna continue to
monitor all the latest developments
surrounding the deep state throughout
the show tonight but first we turn to
our Hannity watch on the government
shutdown so today President Trump
invited Democrats to the White House
he's trying to make a deal he's offering
them every opportunity meited them for
lunch and a meaning to discuss border
security that invitation once again
rejected by oh I'll give you a dollar
Nancy Pelosi and company making it all
the more difficult for the president to
negotiate with a group of people how do
you negotiate when they won't come to
the table to talk and this comes as a
new migrant caravan is on the move now
tonight in Honduras according to a human
rights group that's traveling with the
migrants the caravan has now swelled to
approximately 2,000 individuals raising
fresh fears and concerns about more
clashes as they move into the southern
border of Mexico and an of course back
up to the United States without a doubt
this is good for everybody on both sides
of our border if we had physical
barriers and remember a wall makes
everybody safe
we don't want to encourage the journey
which is literally difficult people die
which is subject to human trafficking
physical abuse sexual abuse other
life-threatening conditions for those
that want to come here just for a better
life and I've said many times I think
that's the vast majority of people they
want a better life for themselves their
kids their their grandkids but we've got
to have a system where we vet anyone and
everyone trying to come into our country
they have had Americans that have lost
their lives because of illegal
immigrants ninety percent of the drugs
heroin for example coming into this
country come from our southern border
that makes it a life-and-death matter
not a political ploy and maybe Democrats
should take note because the President's
agenda has been extremely successful
we've got good news on the economic
front tonight German automaker
Volkswagen announced they're expanding
operations in Tennessee that's good news
following the big news the president
tweeted out volkswagen will be spending
800 million dollars in Chattanooga
Tennessee and they will be making
electric cars congratulations to
Chattanooga and Tennessee a job well
done a big win and it gets better
a new poll finding that over 7 and 10
investors the economic fundamentals as
strong and long-term optimism remaining
high Democrats threatened to destroy all
that optimism would therefore left nanny
state socialist dreams like Democratic
mayor of New York comrade bill de blasio
he's actually pushing a new plan
to confiscate that's right confiscate
private property from landlords those he
claims create unlivable conditions and
he's even saying wealth is in the wrong
hands of people in New York well that
sounds like he wants to confiscate money
from some people and redistribute it to
other people
that was coastal comrades out in
California they're now pushing their own
radical far-left agenda with another
nanny state proposal to ban paper
receipts but this paper is filled with
quote toxins so America better wake up
socialism is on the rise in the move and
taking over the Democratic Party
meanwhile unemployment is in the at a
record low record low for African
Americans Hispanic Americans Asian
Americans women in the workforce
consumer confidence remains high wage
growth is the best it has been in a
decade but Democrats threatening to turn
back
all this progress Hawaii taxes
burdensome regulation and of course they
don't want any energy independence
someone even a 70 or 80 percent tax rate
socialized medicine government mandated
climate change all while making our
nation left safe less secure because
they want to fire ice on want open
borders they want to control your
business they want to control your
decisions they want all the power and
they want all your money how does that
make your life better